so
you know when people look at moore's law
they often talk about it as just so the
exponential function is actually
um a stack of s-curves so
basically it's you
milk or whatever take the most advantage
of a particular little revolution and
then you search for another revolution
and it's basically
yes revolutions stack on top of
revolutions do you have any intuition
but how the heck humans keep finding
ways to
revolutionize things well first let me
just unpack that first point that
i talked about exponential curves but no
exponential curve continues forever
it's been said that if anything can't go
on forever
eventually it will stop and and that's
very profound it's very profound
but it's it seems uh that a lot of
people don't appreciate that half of it
as
well either and that's why all
exponential functions eventually turn
into some kind of
s-curve or stop in some other way maybe
catastrophically
and that's a captain with covet as well
i mean it was it went up and then it
sort of you know at some point
it starts saturating the the pool of
people to be infected
there's a standard epidemiological model
that's based on that
um and it's beginning to happen with
moore's law or different generations of
computer power it happens with all
exponential curves
the remarkable thing is you allude the
second part of your question
is that we've been able to come up with
a new s-curve on
top of the previous one and do that
generation after generation
with new materials new processes and
just extend it
further and further i don't think anyone
has a really good theory about
why we've been so successful in doing
that um
it's great that we have been and uh i
hope it continues for some time
but it's uh you know one
beginning of a theory is that there's
huge incentives when other parts of the
system
are going on that clock speed of
doubling every two to three years
if there's one component of it that's
not keeping up then the economic
incentives become really large to
improve that one part it becomes a
bottleneck
and anyone who can do improvements in
that part can reap huge returns
so that the resources automatically get
focused on whatever part of the system
isn't keeping up
do you think some version of the moore's
law will continue
some version yes it ar it is i mean one
version that has
become more important something i call
kumi's law which is
named after john kumi who i should
mention was also my college roommate but
he
identified the fact that energy
consumption
has been declining by a factor of two
and for most of us that's more important
you know the new iphones came out today
as we're
recording this i'm not sure when you're
gonna make it very soon after this yeah
um
and for most of us you know having the
iphone be
twice as fast you know it's nice but
having it
the battery life longer that would be
much more valuable
and the fact that a lot of the progress
in chips now is reducing energy
consumption
um is probably more important for many
applications
than just the raw speed other dimensions
of moore's law
are in ai and machine learning
those tend to be very parallelizable
functions
um especially uh deep neural nets
and so instead of having one chip you
can have multiple chips or you can have
a
a gpu graphic processing unit that goes
faster and now
special chips designed for machine
learning like tensor processing units
each time you switch there's another 10x
or 100x improvement
above and beyond moore's law so i think
that the raw
silicon isn't improving as much as it
used to but these other dimensions
are becoming important more important
and we're seeing progress in them
i don't know if you've seen the work by
open ai where they show the
exponential improvement of the training
of neural networks
just literally in the techniques used so
that that's right
almost like the algorithm the it's it's
fascinating to think like can i actually
continue
let's i was figuring out more and more
tricks on how to train networks faster
faster the progress has been staggering
you know if you look at image
recognition as you mentioned
i think it's a function of at least
three things that are coming together
one we just talked about
faster chips not just moore's law but
gpus tpus and other technologies
the second is just a lot more data i
mean we are awash in digital data
today in a way we weren't 20 years ago
photography
i'm old enough to remember it used to be
chemical and now everything is
digital i took you know probably 50
digital photos yesterday
i wouldn't have done that if it was
chemical and and we have the internet of
things and all sorts of other
types of data are when we walk around
with our phone it's just broadcasting
a huge amount of digital data that can
be used as training sets
and then last but not least um as they
mentioned at open eye
as they mentioned at openai there have
been significant improvements in the
techniques
you know the core idea of deep neural
nets has been around for a few decades
but the advances in making it work more
efficiently have also
improved a couple of borders of
magnitude or more
so you multiply together you know 100
fold improvement in
computer power 100 fold or more
improvement in data
100 fold improvement in in
techniques of software and algorithms
and soon you're getting into
million-fold improvements
you